on va revenir sur le harcèlement que les
candidats subissent sur les réseaux à
chaque diffusion le dimanche 17 octobre
2021 combat j'aurais bien l'avoir
d'ailleurs combat comme beaucoup a réagi
dans sa story 1 staal a passé un gros
coup de gueule à la suite de menaces et
de harcèlement dont elle est victime
quotidiennement à mahdia ce que toi tu
as vu des trucs comme ça ou pas du tout
franchement je n'ai eu aucun à m'avoir
que là je viens de recevoir une
notification de combat et à quoi il ya
une demi-heure où justement il ya
quelqu'un qui insultent et au moins est
combat de chimpanzés aulas fait quel
abruti
mais quelle bande d'abrutis sans rigoler
mais fermez vos gueules non mais sans
déconner porter ces combats combat vous
voyez là m'a envoyé là bas que j'ai
embrassé passé faut porter plainte
grasset on n'en peut plus de ces abrutis
sur les réseaux sociaux franchement ça
c'est insupportable
c'est exactement ce qu'elle compte faire
donc on m'a dit voilà avant voyez là la
capture d'écran et amady ba écoute c'est
ce qui me reste à faire donc je portais
plainte et mais ça devient ce genre
qu'alain franchement c'est pas ça
devient une manie de faire koh lanta
plutôt dit je vais faire koh lanta les
gens rigolaient je vais je fais pas et
j'ai pas trouvé la mulette je vais m'en
prendre plein la gueule ça devenait
insupportable sur tf1 a réagi chers
téléspectateurs depuis plusieurs
semaines les aventuriers de koh lanta
sont régulièrement attaqués sur les
réseaux sociaux nous tenons à rappeler
que l'émission reste un jeu et que les
insultes menaces et messages haineux à
l'égard des candidats n'ont pas lieu
d'être voilà
il on est franchement c'est
insupportable et les internautes
dénoncent l'hypocrisie des candidats et
de la production puisque il est si koh
lanta est une émission que nous aimons
tous commenté il est important de le
faire dans la bienveillante et le
respect d'autrui bonne émission combat
et jacques qui partagent des critiques
physique envers anne xlx norad sur love
story mais après ça va venir parler
d'harcèlement hypocrisie voilà donc qui
sait que c'est parti dans un débat c'est
vrai que j'ai jamais muté sur ça c'est
que c'est vraiment très grave et que le
koh lanta qu'on connaissait il ya des
hommes vous était hyper feelgood où les
gens regarder avec plaisir aujourd'hui
vous êtes et des victimes finalement de
votre de vos prestations chauffe ça
assez fou
il permet avait pas il y avait à
l'époque parce que moi je me rappelle
j'ai fait mon koh lanta le premier en
2012 avec ça et il n'y avait pas autant
les réseaux sociaux combien aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est devenu
cc c'est exagéré aujourd'hui on a même
des candidats au jeu de koh lanta qui
bat vivent un petit peu aussi des
réseaux sociaux d'instagram par rapport
aux placements de produits compagnie
donc aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux ont
pris une place et nombre on se place
aussi dans koh lanta avant les gens qui
voulaient participer à koh lanta c'est
des gens qui étaient fans de l'émission
maintient aujourd'hui il ya des gens
veulent participer à koh lanta juste
pour se dire que bah je passe par le
biais de koh lanta pour ensuite faire de
la télé par derrière donc c'est aussi
devenu un business pour des gars moins
de dire qu'ils m'envoient aussi des
messages qu'on embrasse me dire qu'il me
regarde mon chéri que j'aime fort et
c'est vrai qu'ils m'envoient des
messages que voilà que vous recevez
c'est incroyable on regarde et on a on a
relevé dean de rudes alexandra même
belle elle est moche mais basta dégage
coumba clément petite clémentine mais
quelle conne mais bouffonne clémentine
c'est pas possible d'être reconnu comme
ça ptdr salle smith dégage claude de
merde claudine dégoûte vas-y des gars
jouaient ce fils de [ __ ]
beauté signaler ces gars là où bat
hollywood bouffonne à chialer tu mérites
que ça claude fdp tu te prends pour qui
mais c'est dingue son pastèque alix la
plus grosse te plus de koh lanta
voilà annoncé voilà voilà donc sam après
moi comme justement c'est que toutes ces
personnes là qui sont là qui allait
décider parce que je vais vous montrer
la violence raciale mais c'est vrai
parce qu'ils ne seront pas content et ça
j'en ai pris une dizaine c'est à dire
qu'on a c'est étonnant mais koh lanta ça
fait 4 million deux cent mille
spectateurs vous imaginez un peu le
déferlement la presse assez une minorité
1 parce qu'il n'ya pas y'a pas forcément
quand vous regardez bien c'est pas tout
le monde est là normalement ces mêmes
personnes qui vous insulte quand ils
vont croiser dans la rue ils disent on
veut faire une photo exactement je sais
je sais mais je voulais c'est pour ça
que l'on ne pas enlever ça mais je
connais la frange écrit un livre
insupportable qu'on doit juste laisser
passer non bien sûr bien sûr faut
laisser passer la marge sur coûts et
porté plainte bien sûr c'est ce qu'il
faut macoumba coumé battu le mans sera
très fort de ma part puis et l'avenir
c'est avec plaisir et n'a pas dire que
tu viens de voir contenu ils essaient de
voir prochainement pour qu'on travaille
ensemble sur des projets ok pourquoi pas
en toi a foutu va faire de la gym
va réfléchir tous les deux